so simon uh indicating that the black
bishop was holding up those white pawns
it's still is still definitely magnus on
the defensive is the uh kind of two
versus one majority now black has one on
the king side but the white king will
hold up any black pawn advances it's
just about the other flank if white can
somehow win the black bishop for his
pawns on the left side then he has great
winning chances
okay magnus just waits
and is he going to offer a trade of
rooks potentially here
yeah
if the rooks come off the board remember
black will blockade on the light squares
white can't break through on that color
complex
then they will immediately sort of agree
a draw somehow be a very quick
quick path towards a draw so can ding
keep the rooks on the board that is the
question for example white's rook can go
up to the top of the board to give a
check
but no
trades off
absolutely i thought that check would be
happening and maybe
i think he needed to unfortunately these
players go it is a draw it is a draw